este problema dice expresa el área de un
rectángulo de base 4 y altura 2
como un mono mío aquí tenemos la figura
y el área de un rectángulo está dada
multiplicando la base por la altura
entonces déjame escribir eso el área es
igual a la base por la altura la base es
4 y 4 y la altura es 22 y déjame
reacomodar esto utilizando la propiedad
asociativa y la propiedad conmutativa de
la multiplicación me voy a reescribir
como 4 por 2 porque porque simplemente
cambie el orden de los factores para
juntar las 10 y los números y ahora sí
vamos a multiplicar este 4 por 2 este 4
por 2 que nos queda un 8 esto de aquí es
igual a 8 y luego eso hay que
multiplicarlo por este deporte y
jefferies ya cuadrada y lo mismo que
llega a la 1 por llegar a 1 que bueno es
de cuadra y cuadrada entonces ahí está
ya tenemos el área expresada como un
mono mió porque esto justo es un
polinomio de un solo término